aber die operative verantwortung liegt
natürlich bei der kommission link war
hat ja gleich gesagt die kommission hat
zu wenig bestellt also es ist klar dass
es an der kommission liegt wie die
umstände waren warum man so entschieden
hat das lässt sich aus meiner sicht
schwer nachvollziehen
das müssen andere beurteilen aber fakt
ist es ist zu wenig bestellt waren ja
zum teil auch von den falschen
herstellern was mich gewundert hat es
scheint auch sehr eine große preis
debatte gewesen zu sein
was mich wundert wenn man überlegt was
für enorme summen wie in deutschland
ausgeben müssen für überbrückungshilfen
für entsprechende maßnahme da wäre das
deutlich günstiger gewesen zu impfen
klappt der gesundheitsministerien sparen
ist da rund um die uhr im einsatz er hat
übrigens im vergleich zu anderen ländern
mehr bestellt was auch dazu führt dass
es selbst innerhalb europa schon
debatten gegeben hat ich habe gelesen
dass ist der kritik ab dass deutschland
mehr bestellt hat und an ein impfchaos
ist es übrigens nicht das ist ein
quatsch denn es wird ja alles was da ist
ordentlich verimpft das problem ist der
impfstoff selber ist noch nicht
ausreichend vorhanden grund wer zum
beispiel auch notwendig dass die
zulassung zu anderen impfstoffen die in
anderen ländern der welt bereits
getroffen wird indien beispielsweise
großbritannien dass wir auch die
zulassung natürlich mit sicher der
prüfung auch beschleunigen denn auch ein
zweiter im stoff allein in last für die
situation enorm